bonjour monsieur galy merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors au
revoir président militaire née à la
retraite est ce que ça en fait un civil
oui bonjour c'est une sorte
effectivement de jeu en quelque sorte
des militaires au pouvoir de la junte au
pouvoir notamment avec les pressions
extérieures
c'est un ex militaire qui a été ministre
à la défense d'ibrahim boubacar kéïta et
puis la retraite alors et qui le
militaire ou pas je pense qu'il est
quand même beaucoup
finalement la jante on peut essayer de
contourner les directives de la vidéo
tout à fait alors le président doit
nommer un premier ministre certainement
civile et des ministres tout aussi
civiles peut-être le vice président qui
est le chef de la junte se mettra
lui-même un civil donc au fond on
travaille surtout sur les apparences
mais sur le fond cette nomination a été
décidée il ya lancé par le vice
président actuel mais en fait de chef de
la junte le collège gotha donc on voit
bien que pour le moment malgré les
apparences le pouvoir est aux militaires
là vous disiez à la présidence qui
revient en colonel simi goita c'est le
chef de la junte le message il est clair
la gente militaire veut rester au
pouvoir remanier en tout cas pour
l'instant elle tout à fait insensé je
sais pas si ils ont lu le manuel du coup
d'état notamment militaires me fait sous
déroule comme souvent quand les
militaires passez moi l'expression le
s'incruster au pouvoir donc le mouvement
qui a au fond manifesté dans la rue et
aboutit politiquement à la chute du bk
c'est à dire le m5 se sent frustré
l'imam dicko qui est derrière ce
mouvement a donné un avertissement à la
gente donc il ya au minimum d'intenses
négociations sur la formation du
gouvernement et la cedeao qui fait
de l'ingérence de la communauté
économique des états d'afrique de
l'ouest insiste beaucoup de peur d'une
contagion pour un retour au pouvoir
civil
alors on parlait de la coalition qui
assure ne pas avoir participé au
processus de désignation du nouveau
président et signe donc un que le choix
de bandas ou n'engage que la jambe
est ce que vous comprenez que cette
opposition que ce mouvement du n 5
estime un peur qu'on lui a volé sa
révolution à mais tout à fait alors ce
qui n'empêche pas que les militaires on
le voit notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les consultations dans le
pays soit pour le moment très populaire
mais pour autant effectivement le 5e
estime que au minimum le chef d'état le
nouveau président ou bien le vice
président devrait être issu de leurs
rangs
donc il est possible que cette
nomination qui intervient un jour
symbolique le jour de l'anniversaire de
l'indépendance du mali soit aux formes
provisoire s'il ya trop de contestations
internes et externes alors une
transition de 18 mois est prévue par les
militaires que faudra-t-il y faire
pendant cep a annoncé qu'il ya beaucoup
de chantiers a affaire aux manies c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est cesser
les douze travailler recul puisqu'il ya
un travail intérieur c'est à dire au
fond une refondation de l'état malien en
quelque sorte avec des hommes intègres
comme il a proposé la junte sans quasi
sans casier judiciaire
donc vu le personnel politique civils
maliens sait pas pas toujours évident et
bien entendu des négociations à la fois
avec les mouvements de touareg pour
renouveler ou reconfirmer les accords
d'alger et peut-être d'ailleurs avec les
djihadistes que l'on va à la fois
combattre et avec qui peut-être on va
ouvrir des négociations et puis des
négociations aussi avec l'extérieur avec
la cedeao que l'on a un peu il faut bien
le dire du p en tout cas contourner
pendant ces nominations c'est la galère
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue
spécialiste de l'afrique de l'ouest et
auteur de la guerre on vallières
retrouver aux éditions la découverte
merci